hi i'm evan carmichael and today's one
minute monday is start strong
it's new year so we've all made our
goals our resolutions we've told
ourselves
this is the year right this is the year
that it's gonna happen for me
and we say that every year and then
somewhere along the way we fall off
we drop off and so i want to share with
you one of my favorite secrets
to staying motivated throughout the year
and that is remember your little why's
remember that you are having an impact
on people's lives and the work that
you're doing
is important so for me how i do it is my
youtube comments right every day i wake
up i turn my computer look at my youtube
comments and you guys give me energy and
fuel
by you saying evan this video changed my
life everyone thank you so much for the
inspiration
that makes me want to do it again right
that adds meaning to what i'm doing
and gets me excited to keep on going but
before i had that popular youtube
channel
i made a list i had a powerpoint file
where i collected all the feedback that
i had from customers people saying that
i helped them in some way and i just
looked at that list every single morning
when i woke up
and it gave me energy it helped remind
me that what i was doing
was important i wasn't hitting my goals
yet i wasn't i wasn't
making it big yet but i was still having
a little impact
i was still having impact on people's
lives in a meaningful way even if only
one person and that gave me
motivation to keep going so remember
your little why's
remembering that you are having an
impact on people's lives
adding meaning to what you're doing
gives you the energy
to keep going and it helps you not only
start strong
but stay strong throughout the year
believe
if you want some believe in your inbox
every week to keep you motivated
check out the link below to join my
newsletter